I'm the virologists I'm an immunologist
I've spent my entire life being a doctor
and I'm telling you right now that the
way to defeat kovat is with immunity I
want us to be able to fight this off and
what we're going to do is by
strengthening your immune system by not
smoking by eating healthy foods by
letting people pee in your mouth not
only on your face but in your mouth when
you are getting a steady stream they
call it a golden shower sometimes the
pee there's so much of it it's different
streams coming at once
it sort of erupts like a fountain out of
your mouth and it could be a golden
fountain - this is what builds
antibodies if people are not ejaculating
on you routinely where you're getting
ejaculated on you don't even know it's
coming you don't know where these
viruses are you don't know what's
happening but every now and then you
might sit down somewhere and then all
the sudden you get up - you get up to
leave but you're in a jack EULA and this
happens all the time so if you're not
sitting in ejaculate or people not
ejaculating on or near you you're doing
yourself really you're not doing
yourself any favours out there you know
it is very important that you put
somebody in the bath and then you drink
the bathwater and the bathwater is gone
into the crevices of their anus and in
their vagina and it has washed their
titties and you are supposed to be
drinking that bathwater and that is
again again this is not new this is
something that we've done for years to
fight viruses so why now are we shutting
down why now is it so different why are
you not simply drinking the bathwater
where you get where you you literally
put your head in the top and you
remember this and this is something that
all of our parents used to tell us to do
and and the medical community was behind
this for many many years you would put
your head in the tub and you would drink
the bathwater of somebody who had just
washed their genitals in the water and
this was the way to safeguard your
immune system against a viral attack do
we stay lock down where we have suicide
we have loss of revenue we have people
that are just beating the [ __ ] out of
their children I'm not the [ __ ] out of
my son
every day I just get up and I kick him
right in the face I don't know why that
is
but it just happens after a month this
is true apparently the only reason
you're not beating your kids is you
don't see them